one of the most influential periods in
black american history post-slavery is
the harlem renaissance
an intellectual social and artistic
explosion centered in harlem
new york gotta love it novels like
passing by nella larsen their eyes were
watching god by zora neale hurston and
the poetry of links and hues were
written during this period
and have become important centerpieces
of the american literary canon
still when discussing this topic we tend
to flatten the dynamic personalities and
identities of the black folk responsible
for making this period so iconic
not only in america but as part of the
entire black diaspora
[Music]
according to statistics before 1910 more
than 90 of the african-american
population lived in the american south
due to poor economic conditions and
prevalent racial segregation
around 6 million african americans moved
to the north midwest
and west to places like chicago
pennsylvania and harlem
in this period between 1916 and 1970
known as the great migration
the first great migration 1916-1940 is
what we're concerned with here
today this massive geographical change
was done in order for black americans to
gain initiative opportunities for
themselves that were not available in
the south
of course the north just had their own
non-jim crow flavored kind of racial
issues like
sundown towns but the yankees are in
denial about that
in 1925 the new negro anthology by alan
locke the
dean of the harlem renaissance was
published it launched a new literary
movement that spoke to the emerging new
black urban identities that had been
formed in the aftermath of the great
migration
as george hutchinson put it in the
introduction to the cambridge companion
to the harlem renaissance
the harlem renaissance in literature was
never a cohesive movement
it was rather a product of overlapping
social and intellectual circles
parallel developments intersecting
groups and
competing visions get all loosely bound
together by a desire for racial
self-assertion
and self-definition on the face of white
supremacy
the interplay between intense conflict
and a sense of being part of a
collective project
identified by race energized the
movement and helps account
for our enduring fascination with it
sadly we do not have the time to go
through all the fantastic figures that
made this movement what it is
but we will do our best to ensure
everyone leaves this video understanding
some of the key voices
of the harlem renaissance starting with
the one you probably learned about in
high school
langston hughes born february 1st 1901
aquarius in joplin missouri hughes
became a prolific writer at a very early
age he gained a lasting sense of racial
pride and solidarity from his maternal
grandmother
who fed him a hearty diet of black oral
traditions and stories about her own
activist experiences
he was especially concerned with the
working-class black people
who are often neglected in works trying
to elevate the race
the negro speaks of rivers which was
published in 1920 became hughes's
signature poem
my soul has grown deep like the rivers i
bathe in the euphrates when dawns were
young
i built my hut near the congo and it
lulled me to sleep
i looked upon the nile and raised the
pyramids above it
i heard the singing of the mississippi
when abe lincoln went down to new
orleans
and i've seen its muddy bosom go all
golden in the sunset
hughes works with stress of racial
consciousness and cultural nationalism
that sought to unite people of african
descent
around the globe his works would also
become an important centerpiece of the
negritude movement
in france and the french-speaking
writers of africa
mark a sanders and african-american folk
roots and harlem renaissance
poetry says the sheer volume of hughes's
writings his iconoclastic attitude
towards
black middle-class representation and
most importantly his concern for the
lives and culture of poor and
working-class blacks
has made him the venerable icon of the
harlem renaissance
hughes's legacy is an important part of
not only black american identity
but black consciousness around the world
in his words you see a love and
appreciation for the beauty of his
people
that is what makes his poetry so
powerful across generations
the night is beautiful so the faces of
my people
the stars are beautiful so the eyes of
my people
beautiful also is the sun beautiful also
are the souls of my people zoranil
hurston
born january 7th 1891
capricorn is the most important black
female writer
of all time period initially from
alabama hurston attended new york's
bernard college and columbia university
to study anthropology
and do ethnographic research with a
particular focus on african american
and caribbean folklore hot girl things
in 1936 and 1937
hurston traveled to jamaica big ups and
haiti for research and drew from this
experience
her anthropological work tell my horse
her work as a writer and folklorist was
used in florida's historical and
cultural collection
expanding upon previously undocumented
experiences within black culture
sadly hurston's work slid into obscurity
for decades for both cultural
and political reasons some of hurston's
literary contemporaries criticized her
use of it claiming that it was rooted in
white
racist traditions richard wright in his
review of their eyes were watching god
said
her novel is not addressed to the negro
but to a white audience whose
chauvinistic tastes she knows how to
satisfy
she exploits that phase of negro life
which is
quaint the phase which invokes a pietist
smile on the lips of the
superior race richard wright and i have
beef i strongly disagree with this take
and i think that he
is full of it modern academics like pbs
colleague henry lewis gates jr
have underscored the significance of
hurston's use of this specific language
the narrative voice hurston created her
legacy to afro-american fiction
echoes and aspires to the status of
impersonality
anonymity and authority of the black
vernacular tradition
true somehow to the unwritten text of a
common blackness
correct due to the efforts of alice
walker and other black female academics
hearst's literary star has risen over
the decades deservedly
most recently hurston's manuscript
barracuda was published posthumously
in 2018 now entering from jamaica and
considered
the foremost left-wing black
intellectual of his age
is festus claudius claude mckay
which is the most west indian name i
could think of
i knew he was jamaican just by reading
his name claude mckay is a writer
not as well known today but was a huge
influence on writers like james baldwin
and richard wright
also he was a virgo mckay came to the
united states in 1912 to attend the
tuskegee institute and in 1919 he wrote
and published one of his most famous
pieces of poetry
if we must die during the red summer
a year where white supremacist terrorism
and racial riots took place in more than
a dozen
cities across the united states
relatable
ha oh kinsmen we must meet the common
foe
though far outnumbered let us show us
brave
and for their thousand blows deal one
death blow
though before us lies the open grave
like men we face the murderous cowardly
pack
pressed to the wall dying but fighting
back
when the african-american museum was
opened in dc this poem was read during
the dedication ceremony
mckay along with other caribbean writers
like cyril briggs
richard b moore and willifred domingo
were part of the intellectual black
socialist societies that had been
forming around this time
in 1928 mckay published his most famous
novel
home to harlem which was both a
bestseller
and also controversial for being too
sexy
he attempted to capture the lives of the
uprooted black vagabonds
and did so with such vigor that it was
to the chagrin of many thought it wasn't
respectable enough
mckay passed away in 1948 and in 1977 he
was named the national poet of his
native land of jamaica
and spencer another aquarius holds a
unique place in the history of the
harlem renaissance
because even though she lived outside of
new york city she was still an
important member and key intellectual
player in the movement
spencer was very well published and
anthologized
during her lifetime and was the first
virginian and one of three
african-american women included in the
norton anthology of modern poetry
during her lifetime spencer published
over 30 poems
but sadly a lot of her work has been
lost to the ages
according to a scholar of afro-american
studies carolyn a ferrari
in addition to providing a voice for
black environmental imaginaries
spencer's poetry also challenges
pervasive stereotypes
specific to black women and their bodies
what is unique and remarkable about
spencer's poetry is that
she offers a vision of black womanhood
and the natural world that exists beyond
the ideologies of dominion she offers an
alternative way of
being and thinking about being spencer
is unfortunately a lesser known figure
in the harlem renaissance yet is
supremely important in planning the
season what will become the black
womanist movement
she is also a reminder that despite the
migration north
much of the black historical roots that
we look to
are rooted in the south her home became
an important center of knowledge for the
likes of george washington carver
thurgood marshall martin luther king jr
and w.e.b
dubois ever heard of them nella larson
aries was born in chicago to a
mixed-race afro-caribbean father and a
danish mother
her father was absent in her life
leaving her to be raised by a white
immigrant family
that taught her early on that she would
have no place in white society despite
her light skin this also limited
larson's early access to a black
identity
this disconnect would be an inspiration
for much of larson's work
according to howard university professor
of african american literature gregory j
hampton
it was on until the harlem renaissance
in the arrival of writers such as nella
larson
that realistic images of black women
began to evolve in the african american
literary tradition
among her works larson published two
important novels of note
quicksand and passing quicksand is her
more autobiographical work dealing with
protagonist
helga crane a woman who struggles to
find her identity in a world
of racialized crisis during the 1920s
she like the author has a white mother
an absent black father and no sense of a
clear black
identity passing the more popular of the
two centers on the reunion of two
childhood friends
one of whom is passing for a white woman
married to a racist
white husband in harlem new york it does
not end well for her
also now major motion picture by rebecca
hall
good for her larson did not fit
seamlessly into the new negro movement
because so much of her work dealt with
the unspoken conflicts
of not fitting into your racial identity
larson's passing is about the losses
gained from assimilating into whiteness
and how for black folk it comes with
more traumas not only does it mean a
loss of community and family but also a
total severance of black history for
future generations
unlike the rachel dolezals of the world
these people did not become
white in order to take over white
institutions they became
white to be given a fair shot to survive
in a racist society
to simply be granted full citizenship in
the country of their birth
it is a dark conflict that larson not
only understood as a person but embraced
as a writer before we wrap up we also
have to recognize someone who is
important to
curating the knowledge that we have
about the harlem renaissance
alturo alfonso schomburg historian and
activist
schoenberg was an afro-latino man of
black puerto rican and german ancestry
proudly calling himself afro-puerto
rican
after hearing from his teacher that
black people had no history
he spent his entire life trying to prove
that teacher wrong
and succeeded he collected and
documented the accomplishments of people
of african heritage all across the world
he immigrated in new york city in 1891
eventually landing in harlem
but in 1920 schomburg had amassed a
collection which consisted of artworks
manuscripts rare books slave narratives
and other artifacts of black history
he along with historian civil rights
activist john
edward bruce formed the negro society
for historical research
which brought together african west
indian and afro-american scholars
schomburg's collection is part of the
schomburg center for research in black
culture which is located in harlem
today one of the frustrating parts of
black history month is that
it stuffs so much important history and
legacy into the shortest month of the
year that gets overshadowed by
valentine's day anyway
and you don't have time to get into the
meat of things i never knew how many
queer black people were part of the
harlem renaissance the
infighting between important figures the
structures of feminism that were being
built
and the way it melded black american and
black immigrant struggles
into this major city i'm from brooklyn
i've been to harlem many times
but it wasn't until i got older started
doing my own research that i got a real
understanding of its history this video
ideally isn't just a quick overview of
the greatest hits of this literary era
it is an invitation to you to do your
own research to read up on these really
interesting players of one of the golden
ages of black intelligentsia
you will not regret it there is a lot of
drama
a lot of drama and also it's just an
important part of history that matters
365 days of the year not just in
february
so go enjoy there's plenty of stuff to
[Music]
devour
you